for the first time this season the mets
will give francisco lendore a breather
in game two of this doubleheader he will
not start francisco lindor who now is in
such an incredible slump one of the
longest slumps of his career over his
last 24 1 for 18 with runners in scoring
position and now it's johan oviedo here
in 2021
and he'll get the start for saint louis
a couple of games this year and he's
made one start the other was in relief
of a start made by daniel ponce de leon
swang and a mess held on to by sanchez
so he's gotten the first two miguel
castro making his first start as a met
and as you said earlier gary
241
major league appearances this will be
his third start
in 242
first since july 2018
and castro strikes out goldschmidt with
the slider and that's the second out
castro's got a nice arsenal boy i tell
you
he's got an excellent slider you know he
did a lot of starting pitching in the
minor leagues
oviedo taking a long look in
left leg kick the payoff pitch breaking
ball line to center that's a base hit
for smith and the mets have their first
hit of the game you know the hits off
breaking balls have been few and far
between for dom this year but he gets
one there leading off in the second and
a breaking ball in the strike zone
kind of a lazy breaker and dom covers it
nicely
that's pole down the line and a fair
ball it's going to bounce off the
sidewall heading to third is smith and
pilar pulls in at second base
right along the chalk down the left
field line and pilar
has himself a double and the mets are in
business second and third nobody out
malar had another nasty breaking ball
right there pitchers pitch
look at that down and away that went out
with one hand and a 2-2 pitch by johann
oviedo
vr hits a fly ball
[Music]
[Applause]
left
catch made dominic smith is going to
hold up
the key first out o'neal sets up makes
himself a strong throw
0-2
center field will they test him here
catch made that's bader here comes a
throw
and they're going to hold up the runners
again
could be a inning that the momentum
shifts
again in favor of st louis thirdly good
the mets need a head here
they got to score a run so now it's left
to tomas needham
that gets away from sanchez and that
will bring in the game's first run
[Applause]
dom smith scrambles home on the wild
pitch and the mets laid in one nothing
well not a good play by sanchez they're
backhanding
instead of with a runner on third you've
got to be extra diligent
pilar at third
two and one denito
and he gets a breaking ball and drills
it out to left center field backhoes
o'neill takes a look and it's out of
here
thomas nedo with his first home run of
the year and it's three-nothing new york
so after the mets couldn't get the run
home with a couple of short fly balls a
wild pitch brings in one and the very
next pitch is a hanger and neato makes
no mistake two run homer in the mets of
a three-run second inning
well tomos gets a hanging breaking ball
and he got it third hit of the season
get down the left field line by sanchez
and that's in the corner in fair
on his way to second base
two out double jordan yamamoto hangs a
breaking ball and sanchez makes him pay
for it
that thing rolls in there he does a good
job getting barrel to it keeps it fair
and that's his first major league
extra base hit so two outs and a runner
at second johan oviedo
up the middle and a basement for oviedo
sanchez around third he's going to try
to score the throw to the plate by pilar
and he is out at the plate
kevin pillar guns down ali sanchez
trying to score oviedo has his first big
league hit
but it winds up being an out they need
to retrieve that ball that's his first
hit
mets get the out of the plate though at
least three nothing after two yeah kevin
pillar comes up firing
nice hit we were messing around talking
about how hitterish oviedo looks that's
a nice throw jonathan vr playing
shortstop in this game oviedo downhill
1-0
vr hits it hard and deep high toward
left field back four and watching it go
is o'neill it's a home run
jonathan vr punches one out the other
way
it's an opposite field homer to put the
mets up four to nothing
as jonathan vr has his first home run in
a mets uniform mets don't hit many
that's only their 20th home run and yet
they've had two in three innings this
being their what 25th game i think more
than anything when the mets were
thinking of making the change with their
hitting coaches it was because they
don't hit
enough home runs don't even hit that
many fly balls so carlson
batting for oviedo who went four
loop the lefty delivers and there's a
base hit to right field trying to hit
the ball the other way again
and he comes through driving in tyler
o'neill and the cardinals are on the
board and carlson is very happy at first
base you don't often see a lot of
emotion from him but just exactly what
he wanted to do and it's 4-1 new york
and the first
earned run
allowed by german jordan yamamoto
against the cardinals and it happened
after he left the game
3-2 to carpenter and he flies one out to
right conforto has it lined up
and that retires the side so loop after
bending gets a big out cardinals set up
for just the one run kevin pilar up with
two out and two on mets up four to one
in the fifth
and the curve ball hit out to right
fading fast that ball is
on the ground for a base hit mcneal will
score
conforto to third
pillar with an rbi single and it's 5-1
new york edmond playing right field got
a bit of a slow start made the diving
attempt and just came up short and
pillar just continues to produce
well this kind of serves this one out
there breaking ball away
illegeretti now the pitch
and a bouncing ball slowly hit to third
tough play arenado bear hands throws and
safe is the call a run scores
conforto comes home from third
piar to sepalar to second and on at
first with an rbi infield single is
jonathan vr and the mets now lead six to
one there's talent o'neill who scored
the only st louis run he grounds one
toward the whole vr on the backhand the
long throw to first is off target
beautiful play jonathan vr
side retired
vr getting to start it short for the
first time this year with lindora
sitting in the nightcap and he makes a
gem it was really good there first pitch
is grounded to the left side that's
going to be an infield hit for justin
williams if he can beat it out and he
does infield hit and an rbi and
a rough last step for williams and he
may have tweaked something in his foot
he seems okay
that's lined the other way by dom
and the dive and it's in and out of the
glove of o'neill and everybody's safe
and the mets have the bases loaded would
have been a great catch
oh he had it
just couldn't hold it drove in a run
with the base at his last time up and he
grounds this one weakly to short de-yong
goes for the tag makes the throw not in
time as a run comes home one two coming
from familia
line the other way and mcneal snags it
and the ball game is over familia gets
the final three outs the mets get a
split of the doubleheader and it's the
bench guys getting starts pilar vr and
neato each with two rbis